google weekends in jail what would you  do would you rather just bang it out in  a year get it over with it would you do  five years of weekends in jail what  would you do so you can go to jail come  out and then go to jail come out go to  jail you literally monday you're free  you're out  oh [ __ ] you can't go to weddings  yeah you can't you can't get into comedy  you can't watch you can't you know go to  football  okay it's not a jail you're in i don't  know that's a tough one imagine you're  like hanging out with someone like and  then like they're like yo tomorrow we're  going to the game you want to come like  i can't  i [ __ ]  i kicked a lady in the vagina a couple  of years ago and uh my saturdays and  sundays are locked up for a few years